now can you smoke we know it might sound
like a dumb question but I do know
people in recovery who do smoke that's a
mistake
marijuana maintenance okay again I'm not
[ __ ] on it if they're smoking weed
if smoking weed keeps you from doing
opiates or heroin yeah fine lesser evil
absolutely but let's not kid ourselves
like you are exchanging an ADD addiction
and someone with the brain come in
there's people who are pot heads that
are not drug addicts there's definitely
people who are drug addicts that pot is
their drug of choice so how you can go
on you so what dude you'll just do
nicotine now you won't touch anything
else caffeine and nicotine is the only
thing going through those don't seem to
trigger that system that rewards system
that's assertion will you drink dr. drew
drink alcohol yeah sure no it's a week
you're what I'm up to nights week maybe
yeah what's your drink of choice I was
like wine but I'm on this you know carb
free things I'm bourbon Carnival oh good
for you I'm very ma'am yeah that's a
legend I got I don't smoke weed and I
smoked weed last night I don't want to
drugs lately I'm a drug addict okay this
quarantine thing is research for school
I was kidding about that but I will if
it's around all right let me let me tell
you something right now I did I smoked I
took two hits
I don't know from weed I was so [ __ ]
high I don't know how people can think
they could function on this I guess they
do I literally was like maybe you can
understand maybe you can answer this for
me when I do when I smoke weed I feel
every pain in my body I can feel my body
insanely and I start to get paranoid and
I go I think my neck is gonna [ __ ]
paranoia
is that what it is yeah and then I
paranoid a pan and then I watch that
Harvey on Price is Right flips and I
laugh part of my life they do where
we're in Austin we were with Aubrey
where we're at I don't know where some
girl's apartment is I was making you man
medium got high and off weed you were
laughing so hard that laughing is the
one I thought would fall off the edge of
the yeah I was making him laugh it'll
make it'll make really mediocre
entertainment Fanta
I uh oh my god I didn't know that
beginner I heard you guys got to
recognize like you're two both perfect
examples the human body it's chemistry
so unique from person to person yeah I
know
like a you and I are the same and when I
used to body build there was a guy named
Mike Salcido and we both trained
together we were both almost exactly the
same size he was 510 about 185 and we
trained together too for a show together
to work towards it we both had the same
guy doing our nutrition a couple weeks
out from the show he was eating three
400 grams of carbs a day if I ate over
50 I'm asleep
you know so that just giving you some
idea about chemistry of us like there's
people like like Joey Diaz his brain
just it kicks in the weed he's ready to
do it let's do much better some people
you're done for tonight without
Fleming's me go to sleep
I knew Annette other people go up yeah
it is Korean girl named Mary she was 75
pounds I mean honestly she was this tall
and she could eat hay I watching
handfuls of vicodin and guzzle it's just
good ghazal and she was just straight
like Lemmy she was like a little agent
and then and then I had a buddy was an
offensive lineman at UCLA and he took up
a pill and it's [ __ ] oh that's fine
saying like everyone's Kim she's all I'm
sick of the tiger King I'm over it now
because we found out he doesn't really
make his music complete [ __ ] lying
what do you mean he hired someone to
make his music yeah but he sings no
that's not his voice he hired a guy I
know it's why they came out like that's
our music no we wrote in saying he just
dubbed his mom he's such a [ __ ] bad
guy oh my God he's such a piece inside
another three years that 20-year
sentence for being a piece of [ __ ]
that's hilarious I thought he had a
great oh my god man I thought he had a
great voice nope
that's fantastic they'll be and give you
a hell the deal on the tiger that I can
vouch one give you a good deal the wild
west CBD commercial there we go we can
play for fans right chin yes yes sir
I want the released outtakes of us
laughing and you doing it yeah they're
going this idea dude you're gonna love
this
you look young about the CBD industries
like the Wild West you never know what
you're gonna get I represent pure
spectrum you know exactly what you're
gonna get so I ride into this lawless
like old country town right now I'm
representing here spectrum on the
sheriff I'm all of them big burly horses
I like a brown horse and I and then all
the townsmen they circle around they
just all gathered because they represent
the other see big deal tell me they
don't want me in there okay they found
real are they're bad guys I'm good guy
their guns I'm good guys they have guns
and they take them out I hear one go hey
stick cowboy we don't want you coming
around here
sees that matter of fact now and he goes
get on out of here and I go cuz they
don't want pure spectrum in the market
why would they fly with them and then
all make your move boy and then I see
one girl come out the bar she's like
don't hurt him and I'm like sweetie Bob
take it from here and they draw their
guns I'm like oh we're doing this not up
in here y'all they're just all laid out
no sick man I think it's slow motion as
a lotta horse right like I'm going and
there's like smoke and the town's blown
up behind me like this
my horses aren't the innocent people
there no they brand in the food in the
single oh that's a thick ass cowboy and
how are you riot sweetie I know what the
town's the tempie and then in slow
motion it's like pork and then I'm
looking like super smoky and then even
while horses slow motion goes and
pirated the Canada pure cbv in this town
and it's pure spectrum partner love it
you do I knew it this makes me want to
use pure spectrum you know what do you
think the mustache is it too much
no yeah here's the thing this is the
magic with Brian town there was no scrip
for that we did that on the spot if we
did it on us to do that on the spot on
the spot it was all on the spot yep
Brian got throw here's what I'm thinking
Brian goes try this and then we'd go
through it and then we do we have so
many outtakes and me and just me and him
switching it up because I wanted to have
just this women kind of setting them up
and they did a great job great you know
all the way yeah yeah there's no script
for that street we work well together
yeah okay so this was sent in from
Christian Cassini and apparently the tea
fat K Bobby Lee molesting the story is
going viral on tick-tock it has 17
million views Oh 1.7 but 1.7 million
lights no [ __ ] somebody uploaded it onto
tik-tok and I was just going viral
really yeah let me see it that's the
thing we can't access it
yeah for some reason I couldn't I was
just Bobby tell us about him get blasted
me and Brian uh try not to like that
exact the guy was he's so [ __ ] funny
so funny cuz he kept making he kept
exaggerate making it worse every time
yeah he kept making worse he knew what
he was doing he was torturing so funny I
don't remember I remember less laughing
I'm her strike I was laughing saying I'm
slapped you I think right no not that
time
last time he came he hit me with the
shoe my knee that really hurt it [ __ ]
hurt I love Bobby he's the greatest he's
so fun to get us with the young kids
yep tick-tock what's the other video you
posted see this um just how to play
everyone's ask me how I played it I just
played it by yourself it she was really
singing this this is from the tiger King
you know that's not one of the songs
that he does
[Music]
is releasing all the clouds that came in
can't believe that
[Music]
and the cat stars our cats featured
touch your lower back
[Music]
because you
I'll be great for five get 3d - is give
the right to massage in another video
oh yeah Brian dressed up like tigers
[Music]
cats all Snow Leopard
a little cloud leopard it's really nice
cool thank you
really really good what was the other
video had on their chin let's get a lot
of views this one like jiggle is this
that what is this one the day in the
life of oh mine yeah can I see this sure
it's just a little like a straight hair
it's usually at a dead stop
yes free flowing like crazy right now
this is my apartment I won't show you
too much that Prius you have a Prius now
yeah these are at a free longest time
second card to the snow off the tee flat
Cairo blow the belts to do I'm secure
and format I love Kevin Kross adorable
the best there's Brian this Jimbo
Henderson
[Music]
heading back she'll show us your girl
chip I mean not sure dude I line 6 3 7 7
watch it dick whatever force was treated
22 times I explained I do him back when
he was a rock star that really aids and
I build not alone he's Polonius monster
yeah and I'd never heard every one you
got it this guy's dying get away we
didn't he cannot be oh yes yeah he was
one of the examples in one of the
slipperiest slowly rehab counselor there
they got they have the glasses yes and
and and I was giving a lecture one day
and there was a guy sitting in the front
row look just like him was like 15 years
later and the whole time I'm lecturing
I'm thinking Jesus Christ how weird guy
looks like pop for us well he's dead
there's no way it's Bob for us and lo
and behold he had recovered and became
this very talented clinician you know
where people I'll kick out of treatment
well somebody come up to me years later
and go shake my hand to go you know I
wasn't ready to hear at the time but
you're kicking me out was one of the
important things that got me where I am
and now I'm getting my PhD I took ology
I told the girl what time I was dating I
swear to God I was young I was too
stupid and she was she was an actress
and she kept talking my how she had
worked with such-and-such but she had
been an extra on things and then I
helped her with an audition and one day
I looked at her I go I go can I be
honest they she's never done this you
see I go I don't think you're an actress
I don't think you have it have you seen
the effects yes that's was that's a
scene in effect yeah she called me
ten-year five years later and said I
just want thank you I have a great life
and I and you were right and she [ __ ]
walked out on me she what I mean
we that's another thing we weirdly in
like the only last like 20 years
Americans have adopted this like your
dream can come true and it's like hmm oh
I can dream all I want about being on
the Lakers
yeah I'll Nev that won't ever I have
like a 20 inch vertical and I'm five man
you can dream about being Jared Leto
it's not gonna happen so I have the
bones from do with Anvar even if you
were a junkie you would come down to
about 200 225 if
I'm taking afraid I get down the two to
twenty five to ten you'd still be huge
you know how [ __ ] up mob force was no
Anthony Kiedis said well I can't party
with that guy yeah when he's like that
guy pull that guy's pulled the day at
the Hayes house down twice oh my god
have you have you seen that documentary
everybody's talking about Tiger King oh
yeah there has to be some addiction oh
it's all drug addicts right they gotta
be the one that's oil fire white my wife
and I watch and we just like oh Jesus
some of that drug addicts I'm Tiger
because more importantly have you seen
homeboys nanny
that's the most important myth he sleeps
with they're good for him one of the
owners the real shitty what he was
looking for her he goes to the computer
he's looking through looking at this
headshots essentially and then wife's
like I don't know he goes yeah went up
something to look at why not oh my gosh
mom I just want for one second the idea
of bringing her home for my man look at
my wife's face oh that guy is such a
psychopath they were so mad yeah it's a
mixture of these like like it's like
insanity drug halti stuff with the guy
with the weird the guy with all the
girls that he